in the rubble of this building the
search continues
not for life
but for the dead
bombs ripped through the kharkiv
administration building on march 1
leaving only debris twisted metal and
dust
one bomb came through the roof
others fell outside
leaving a crater and destruction for all
to see
we catch the workers on a break
they tell us over the last few days
they've found four bodies
day after day they return
i think many here face such a large
number of victims among civilians for
the first time
as they say one death is a tragedy but a
thousand deaths are a statistic
we don't have time for feelings now we
put them aside
but we will have to deal with them later
it's not an easy process
now we have work to do
we focus on it
this was the kitchen
to the cafe
next door
everything
has been
destroyed
pink walled cafe pictures on the walls
but there's one thing that does
stand out and it's quite striking
you can smell the fact that there's
still
dead bodies there's remains
still here
we're standing on fifth floor here
most most of us it was military guys
just we just received weapon
we met jenny in the ruins of the
building
he had just finished his morning
briefing when
and about 8 am first rocket came
and hit
near this building
all windows were crashed
first
injuries
and 10 minutes later i was i
went down
on third floor and second rocket
attacked this building right there
and everybody who was standing
on each floor on that on the corner
everybody died
so far he hasn't been face to face with
his enemy this war putin's war is war of
rockets
first of all and most of our victims
also
civilian victims army victims today
it's it's uh
these victims is because of rockets of
bombing of air attacks and
ear attack or rocket attack
you just
it's like it's like a lottery it's like
casino you know you can win or you can
lose
i'm alive my guys from my
uh
from my team they're alive because we
are lucky
all the while the search continues
a month into this war they're still
pulling out bodies on a daily basis and
workers here have told us that that grim
task will continue until they've been
through the entire building
and slowly the body count rises
rescue workers provide whatever dignity
they can to their fallen countrymen
as alberg al-jazeera kharkiv